and this one is dragon with the white
pieces versus komodo this is a 15 minute
rapid game let's see what happens it's
about to get crazy here we go so we have
dragon with the white pieces goes d4 and
then b6 and owens system owens defense
it can be played really against
everything that black white plays so d4
b6 from komodo and e4 transposition into
the owens defense usually you will see
e4 then d4 now there's a lot of chess in
this game 60-something moves but we're
gonna slow down a little bit and then
actually speed it up later on so that we
can get through the entire game and not
keep you guys too long so e4 bishop to
b7 is next after bishop b7 bishop to d3
it defends upon this is usually basic
theory that you would see in the owens
defense it's sort of like a french
defense with the bishop on b7 so think
about that so bishop to d3 and then e6
happens which is trying to get the
bishop out very early it's also
attacking this you're going to play
knight f6 now a lot of times especially
people that have problems with this
opening with the white pieces i've had
problems before is playing knight to c3
is immediately going into what they want
in a way it's like a reverse larson
system one b3 like um like
larson himself ben larson and also
hikaru who has a nasty score with the
one sorry b3 right b3 move so after e6
here there's knight two f3 and then c5
which is uh usually move here c5 and
you'll play c3 which happens we bolster
the center
okay after both starting center knight
f6 and queen e2 defending i'm a fan of
playing this way and then castling and
just going for a quick mate as quick as
possible d5 from komodo attacking the
center this is a center type attacking
opening with the pawns and the pieces as
you see kind of like a weird french
because the bishop is on b7 not c8 and
it can't go to a6 so after the e5 move
knight f to d7 and we officially are in
like a real french territory except the
bishop is on b7 that usually doesn't
happen once again so we got the french
advance pawn structure here so we have
castles and knight c6 and then here's
one move that's really cool from dragon
playing h4 for the score saying yo let's
go for it you already know what i want
i'm trying to check me and this king
obviously is not going to go to the
queen side many times because of the c
file being open easy b4 a4a5 and we live
everything five and live bishop a6 is
looking nasty so a lot of times you knew
you know that they're going to castle
this way or the king is going to stay in
the center after the h4 move there is a
h6 from black and then h5 right gaining
more space yes this pawn seems weak but
it can be defended quite easily so let's
make some moves here remember in the
opening it's all about making moves
right getting your pieces out developing
making a plan let's see what happens
after h5 bit should be seven get it off
the back ring knight to a3 doing the
same thing strange but of course maybe
we want to put it on b5 knight on the
rim is dim grim whatever right but
knight a3 is a good move and it actually
develops sometimes you go to c2 as well
so knight c3 a6 stopping knight to b5
and white plays a very nice move here i
like with bishop to b1 tucking the
bishop a tuck and roll here where these
bishops are like snipers and they sit
here waiting to be activated after
bishop to b1 queen to c7 is he going to
castle queen sign we don't know so after
clean c7 knight to c2 bringing the
knight back around
a5 and then rook 2e1 put the rook on the
file with a smile but guys this is a
closed position and in close positions
it takes maneuvering and it takes a lot
of skill so you have to know what you're
doing what the plan is and it takes a
lot of maneuvering hence why this game
was 63 moves it takes a lot of
maneuvering a lot so let's see what
happens after rookie one bishop a6
maneuvering some more hitting the queen
queen obviously moves c takes d4 c takes
d4 and b5 gaining some space usually in
these type of positions white gained
space on the king side trying to
checkmate black gaining space on the
queen side trying to limit checklist
obviously not get checkmated maybe keep
the king here because you like castling
right into mate right king safety is
important not just castling and also uh
queen of the queen side for black is
going to be where we're going to try to
get our advantage and win the game
chapter b5 a3 you know just stopping
some b4 action or maybe knight before
action but he really didn't want that
the dragon didn't want it so queen of b6
trying to insist and then bishop to f4
get the the piece off the back right
rook to c8 bishop g3 a little reroute
maybe we'll go this way a lot of times
you bring a queen and try to attack
these pawns a4 a nice move trying to
gain some more space here right we're
playing on opposite sides of the board
here so let's see what happens a4 and
then knight to e3 rerouting opening up
the bishop here
and then after uh knight 285 you see
bishop c2 right the knight was swinging
into b3 so bishop c2 was played to stop
it but knight c4 can be played there was
no knight c4 uh surprisingly in fact
there was bishop to b7 backing the
bishop and white plays knight h4 now
we're looking at this like oh knight h4
he probably gonna go queen g4 next right
that's probably the next move that's why
he played this you should always ask
yourself what is your opponent going to
do next after knight to h4 what is the
intention of this move shoot it looks
like queen g4 it's simple right queen g4
okay so he does put his knight on c4 and
says all right bro trying to trade these
off my guy time to trade them trying
time to trade him so what do you do in
this position why to move
here it is okay we look at the position
knight takes f5 seems like a move right
i mean maybe we still probably could go
clean g4 it is murky because loose
pieces lose games right or lpdo like
chess kids loose pieces drop off or take
c2 you're looking crazy right if this
does not work means you for the knights
the only thing defending c2 at that
point so um here it is
dragon says you know what
knight f5 and we lied what you thought
this was
yeah it's time to open up yeah big fella
time to open up shop knight e to e5
e e5 f5 now e2 f5 i mean that's uh
that's an amazing move knight takes g7
is in the air there and he says okay oh
okay
says comodo i'm gonna take those you're
gonna have to show me big fella so he
takes it the knight takes f5 very nice
attack here a lot of times you do have
to
sacrifice pieces to open things up and
it's not a weird thing and it's not like
it doesn't happen a lot in the french
defense or simular you will a lot of
times sacrifice pieces in in these
french type positions so this definitely
happened knight takes f5 after knight
takes f5 there was knight to f8 to get
just kind of out of the way defending
squares here obviously two as well and
then what's the next much uh chat and
youtube and everybody watch it
what do you do here knight takes g7
knight e7 e6 how do you continue the
attack
i'm going to tell you one thing here i
probably would have played knight takes
g7 it just felt right maybe some e6 in
there queen g4 maybe in a slow push game
you might find the move here which is
knight to d6
wow
knight d6 check
flex real hard from the big boy engine
here knight to d6 that's a nasty move
here nasty so of course after 1916 d7
i'm not taking this knight i'm just
about to get out the way have a nice day
king d7 instead of taking any of this
stuff he goes queen to f3 for dragon
hitting this pawn i mean bishop at five
this is very weird so we see 96 queen
takes off seven whoa
rook fake queen g6 he like all right i'm
good i'm good i'm out the woods bishop
takes get rid of this knight
i play rook f6 and i'm out the woods
i'm out the woods says komodo we're good
out here
we're good right white to move right to
move now what do you do about this your
queens hanging you know everything you
thought you had is now diminishing i
mean his king does look kind of crazy
and you do have to defend this maybe
there's a queen g7 if we back the queen
up right but you know we're going to
move our queen right right raise your
hand you're moving your queen yeah
yeah we all wrong big fellow bishop f5
bishop f5 we're not moving no queen
round here what did you think this was
bishop f5
and we live i don't care about none of
that says dragon take the queen so he
does rook takes g6 ace takes g6 this is
uh hanging and in fact the engine says
oh it's kind of equal kind of equal and
then after thinking they give it like
you know super equal
after this but equal believing after the
queen sat because the king out here
looking crazy we got the extra pawn all
in the camp defended by the bishop both
the bishops looking nasty here pressure
on the file with a smile so after rookie
eight there's bang hitting
oh yeah you thought this was over didn't
you rick takes e6 hitting splitting
rookie one rookie six
looking rough queen takes b4 rook takes
e6 okay engine evaluation right now says
half the pawn for white
wow half a pawn for white crazy
absolutely nuts here so uh there's so
many checks this bishop is so strong i
mean it looks like you're losing your
queen everywhere honestly
most likely getting made it so what
happens here is knight takes d6 saying
all right cool let me get you one of the
pieces back rook takes and instead of
stepping um into c7 um gg start a new
game he went king to e8 getting out of
the way
right now a little bit of a technique
here let's move on because we do got 30
moves up bishop d7 king e7 bishop h3
look at the bishops the two ops here the
snipers the the boys they working
together bishop h3 rook d7 is looking
nasty after bishop h3 there is a b4
trying to expand trying to do whatever
we can and king h2 nice move
prophylactic tucking the king tuck and
roll get out the way no checks none of
that weird stuff h5 right trying to play
h4 and now it's time to attack so rookie
6 king d8
and then take on b4
right and right here
uh the best move obviously looks like h4
i mean because uh there's like no bishop
takes because of queen right but
komodo actually played this movie
engines make mistakes too
bishop to c8
game over
start a new one get him off the board
it's white to move
what do you do here how do you finish
this bishop ca seems like a move right
but it's not one
here it is simple check you guys got it
rick d6 great job chad that's right rig
d6
rook d6 check if king c7 we're gonna
just put take on d5 and stare at him
real hard gg start a new one that's a
discovery but and now you can't block
with the bishop because i'm going to
take and king e8 which is what happened
in the game we just take on c8 so bishop
takes ca h4 rookie six check
and this one's kinda cool if there's
king d8 there's bishop e5 surprisingly
which is a cool one that's actually what
happened kda bishop e5 queen takes b4
and rook to c6 to defend the bishop
we're gonna back this boy up and hit you
with mate everywhere and of course this
is cover right now so we need to get
bishop d6 in as well queen to b5
attacking we need to defend we defend
everything's defended we got two three
pieces here
usually three pieces is better than a
queen usually usually sometimes depends
on the situation and if the queen is
able to pick off one of the pieces
due to a double attack or a skewer or
something of that sort sort checking
picking up a piece right if they're not
able to do this then they're not going
to win or it's going to be very
difficult for them to try to win the
game d4 right trying to dislodge the
bishop if bishop takes then the work
hangs and black's actually going to be
winning so bishop f4 going somewhere
where it can be defended and anchored
and then d3 uh oh pass pawns must be
bush do you feel a little scared
not at all this is g4 i'm good bro and
then i can also check you here if i need
to got that pawn on lock so queen to b4
hits both of the bishops at the same
time pretty easy move is rick to d7 king
e8 and this next move can you find it
can you find it both your bishops
hanging you gotta defend them
if you move one i take the other
so what do you do about this dilemma
bishop d6 oh that's looking crazy
absolute nonsense
a g3 i mean maybe you could get away
with g3 but there is a queen takes b2 it
looks kind of scary in there kind of
annoying
what do you do
here it is here it is
bishop g5 i mean
the dragon was just out here today doing
everything i mean sacking the queen sack
of peace sack everything made everything
left and right i mean bishop g5 is
beautiful because now if you take the
bishop there's just rick d.a
mate and we great
nasty so queen of bhx stopping all that
then we play f4 to stop it
and at this point this was game over d2
was the move from from black here and
really what you could do i mean you
could even go rook to d8 and still pick
this game up it's going to take a long
time but because you have this under
under wraps and you have to walk the
king over here and take it but an easier
move is just take first axe ask black
what are you doing you went zuzung in
the way zug master zugged out whatever
you want to call it right he's dugged
out you can't really move anything so
black plays a3 and the rest is just
history as we fly through these moves we
take on a3 we take on h3 actually and
bishop check first and then come back
and take on h3 i mean this is like wow
disastrous queen c7 rook check and then
takes takes and this is the position you
left with
dragon just demolished this this game i
mean that was just a great game by
dragon as kim kamodo was trying to pick
up the pieces here king g8 and we about
to just walk the dogs in the park i mean
pretty simple welcome hello hi how you
doing well queen and we mean and that's
me and by the way like look at the
little box that the king is in
you can't even get out of it
you are made it no matter what i could
have moved my king here and here and it
made this a rook if i wanted to right
but the game's over that was wonderful
absolutely wonderful by the way that was
dragon burst komodo i hope you guys
enjoyed it today this is chess.com and
if you enjoyed this video make sure
y'all check out this next one right
above me we'll see y'all on the next one
[Music]
you